welcome to the allmix logic
bioinformatics for precision medicine
program
precision medicine is changing the way
we understand diagnose and treat major
life-threatening diseases this
transformation is driven in part by
computational technologies as well as
high throughput molecular data that is
being collected from patients animal
models and large-scale cell line
experiments
in the program we will explore how the
various omix data types generated in
these studies can be analyzed and
integrated into the clinical process to
understand the basic biology associated
with communicable or infectious as well
as non-communicable or chronic diseases
including diagnostic strategies and
treatment selection development and
repurposing so in the first session
we'll review again the main topics of
the program introduce each one in
greater detail and provide you with a
guide how to use associated resources to
continue this journey after the session
you should have a good sense of
bioinformatic applications in precision
medicine completing the session video
and associated resources will give you a
great grasp on how data analysis skills
and new technologies like next
generation sequencing are used today in
this field you will also see various
examples that you can use to focus on
oncology
neurodegenerative and infectious
diseases in this session we will learn
about clinical and molecular data in the
context of risk profiling diagnosis and
therapeutic decisions
we will also go through various next
generation sequencing data types such as
genomics transcriptomics and
metagenomics
finally we will learn about the process
of how discovery in the lab
leads to real life applications or how
insights from bioinformatics analysis
can be translated to the clinic
to understand clinical decisions where
bioinformatics is used for precision
medicine we will look at various data
sources such as basic information about
patients or clinical data like age sex
ethnicity in their environment
data that describes disease history and
diagnosis treatments and comorbidities
and molecular profiling that allows us
to perform genotyping based on snips in
the dna
identify biomarkers or look at
microbiome composition
clinical data typically includes data
such as demographics labs and medical
history
the list of collected variables can vary
significantly based on each patient in
most cases this data can come from a
variety of sources like electronic
health records medication insurance
claims and family history
for the most part it is divided into
patient information as well as describes
their interactions or encounters with
the medical provider recently the
sources have increasingly digitized and
integrated leading to an expanded number
of variables with various relevancy for
each case
some studies are starting to incorporate
many of the clinical sources of
information with molecular profiling
environmental factors as well as mobile
health and even social media while some
of the data types are more accurate than
others these all have been used to study
disease for example in the current
pandemic all of these have been used to
track disease spread and identify
potential at-risk individuals or groups
pharmaceutical companies are referring
to this as real-world data or data that
can be used to evaluate responses to
treatments and improve selection of
patients candidates for clinical trials
for many diseases molecular data is
increasingly important and relies on
complex bioinformatics analyses
like gene expression analyses commonly
found snips metabolism information and
an array of various biomarkers or
disease and treatment efficacy these
molecular patterns in association with
clinical data can help refine strategies
for diagnostics and therapy selection
new discoveries in molecular data lead
to a better understanding of complex
diseases at the subcellular level and
help identify novel drug targets or
opportunities for drug repurposing
for the clinician advanced molecular
profiling reveals the underlying
biological drivers of disease and can
help explain disease symptoms using
genomics proteomics transcriptomics
epigenomics and even metagenomics these
molecular markers affect how a patient
is diagnosed and lead to a number of
improvements
risk prediction or
risk stratification
prognosis of outcomes for treatment
modalities such as individual drugs or
combinations of drugs
selection of target therapeutics for
patients with complex diseases
and continuous monitoring of disease
changes over time
one of the great examples of how such
treatment has affected cancer is the
example of breast cancer
so we see that from 1971
to 2011
the rate of survival has increased from
about 50 percent
to over 85 percent
one of the reasons was because studying
cancer herceptin was developed as a
targeted therapeutic
it's a monoclonal antibody that has been
used to treat her2 positive breast
cancer patients since the 1990s it works
by targeting the her2 receptor
preventing cancer growth some breast
cancers express too much her2 protein
triggering the cells to multiply very
rapidly today this trend with targeted
treatment has increased
other monoclonal antibodies such as
protrusimob or pergetta have been
developed
the targeted therapy has gotten even
more advanced
tdm1 cadaicla an antibody drug
combination
has been approved for use in the
treatment of her2 positive breast
cancers
antibody drug combinations work like a
smart bomb delivering chemotherapy
directly to cancer cells by attaching to
their her2 positive receptors targeted
therapies have transformed their
approach to breast cancers
and offer an opportunity to cure even
later stage breast cancers in certain
patients now a lot of this is done using
molecular profiling
one such test called oncotype dx
looks at the expression of 21 different
genes in a patient's primary tumor
a tumor's gene expression pattern shows
whether or not it will be responsive to
chemotherapy or whether endocrine
therapy alone such as tamoxifen could be
a better choice a recent study showed
that patients scoring on the low to mid
risk range could safely skip
chemotherapy completely which would lead
to avoiding the hair loss neuropathy
weight loss and other side effects that
often come
with chemotherapy
but this approach has further developed
and today molecular markers of disease
have led to a complete reclassification
of breast cancers into several different
molecular subtypes
these subtypes continue to evolve
leading to a better treatment of this
complex disease which is the fifth
leading cause of cancer related deaths
annually with more than 265 000 people
diagnosed with it in the united states
alone every year
other multi-homic studies help change
the way that we can understand other
cancers such as liver cancer or
heptacellular carcinoma in the 2017
publication in cell reports the cancer
genome atlas research network published
their analysis of integrated multi-omics
data that led to a much better
understanding of liver cancer risk such
as infection with hepatitis b and c as
well as other factors like alcohol
consumption ethnicity and other
comorbidities
such comprehensive studies continue to
yield results even today
more data is being collected and
analyzed by bioinformaticians leading to
an even greater precision and making it
possible to improve the way treatment is
delivered or even find new treatments
that are less harmful and more effective
for certain patients the role of next
generation sequencing in medicine has
changed dramatically over the past
decade to understand why and how let's
look at several methods of molecular
profiling
explore the process of second generation
high throughput sequencing also known as
next generation sequencing or ngs and
see how such data can be analyzed to
discover specific clinically relevant
data points for a medical procedure the
growth in high throughput data is
largely driven by cheaper faster and
more efficient sequencing called next
generation sequencing or simply ngs from
about 100 million in 2001 which is the
cost of what it took to sequence the
full human genome
to approximately 3 million by 2008 and
by 2017
the cost of a sequence genome was close
to 1 000
just recently ultima genomics announced
its goal to make the full genome
sequence available at a revolutionary
cost of 100
this places whole genome sequencing at a
comparable cost
to most tests like the x-ray
recall that it's been over 70 years
since the structure and function of dna
was discovered 50 years have been spent
since that time sequencing the human
genomes
in 2015 the 1000 genome project brought
a significant number of whole genomes
sequenced and available to the research
community
one hundred thousand whole genomes were
already available by 2018
and today there's an ever increasing
number of data sets that are available
to help researchers and clinicians
understand subcellular processes and the
dna
omics data including such that is
provided by next generation sequencing
includes a variety of types
phenomics refers to high throughput
imaging or characterization of phenotype
genomics allows us to identify mutations
in the genome
so what is the observed sequence
compared to the reference
epigenomics allows us to study
epigenetic variation or variation that
is not dependent on the actual sequence
of the genome
this includes such methods as dna
methylation
transcriptomics allows us to understand
gene expression
or how much of a certain gene
is being expressed in a cell or a tissue
this is done using a variety of
platforms
platforms or instruments that produce
digital
omics data
so those can be divided into two types
short read sequencers and long read
sequencers
and they can be used to sequence either
targeted
amplicon or whole genome or untargeted
dna and rna sequences in most cases for
clinical use
we will refer to either whole exome
or targeted panel sequencing because in
most cases whole genome sequences
sequencing
just carries too much information to be
clinically relevant
the number of annotated snips is much
lower
than the total number of positions in
the human genome which is over 3 billion
long genomic variation is typically
calculated by the proportion of known
snips
present in a particular gene
and this can range from genotyping where
we group patients
by
their genotype or
some special features in their genome
and in some cases we are going to be
looking for pathogenic snips
snips
are single nucleotide polymorphisms
or a single nucleotide position that has
been identified as relatively prevalent
in the population or over one percent of
individuals for example bracha 1 and
bracket 2 testing is extensively used to
identify women that are at risk of
developing breast or ovarian cancer in
fact 44 of women who inherit a harmful
bracha-1 genetic mutation will develop
ovarian cancer by the age of 80. to
summarize omnics data can be used to
understand
what is happening
within the tissue or a single cell
and typically
those can include a variety of dna
changes
gene expression changes
epigenetic changes
as well as microbiome changes in the
individual
when combined with clinical or
phenotypic data some of that information
can be clinically relevant
that means that it will be used at
different stages of identifying risk
developing a precise diagnosis
or even selecting treatment that is most
appropriate and effective for the
individual
and that is why next generation
sequencing data is central to precision
medicine most bioinformatic analyses
are going to be considered as
pre-clinical that means it is based on
data generated in lab experiments or
retrospective studies
to explore these let's look at examples
of cell lines derived from patient
tumors in oncology
animal models of human disease
and explore how these can be used
alongside databases on various specific
diseases for example tcga and oncology
then we will discuss how such insights
can be validated and what considerations
they bring to biobanking and clinical
trials next generation sequencing
technologies and experiments are already
affecting research
hospitals and are used by pharmaceutical
industry to design
specific treatments
and adapt them to the needs of
individual patients
a lot of times
not all of these experiments
are possible on real patients
instead
we can select tumors in different types
of patients
produce those tumors as immortalized
cell lines and use those cell lines to
understand the basic biology
unfortunately that biology cannot be
fully studied just using cell lines
because cell lines
don't have all of the elements of the
system or the whole body that actually
functions as a whole
and so in many cases in oncology instead
of just using cell lines there are also
tumors that could be extracted in full
from a patient grafted into an animal
model
and then studied in terms of their
interaction with the rest of the body
ultimately such experiments
can provide better insights into
biological factors that are relevant for
patients
and different types of tests could be
first performed on these models
before we actually develop a clinical
trial
where such treatments or diagnostic
procedures are used on actual patients
this is also changing the way that we
apply big data analysis techniques or
bioinformatics in real world clinical
needs so typical
process is to collect integrate and
analyze big data coming from a variety
of sources and ultimately change the way
that this can be used in a big data
approach for precision medicine we can
see this oftentimes used when large
scale data is being collected on a
particular disease a good example is the
cancer genome atlas the cancer genome
atlas is a work performed over several
decades to collect samples with
multi-omic data on patients and use
their clinical phenotypes to find
important associations the cancer genome
data is available through the genome
data commons portal that allows us to
find multi-omics data sets with clinical
information about each sample which
gives a much better understanding of how
cancer variation is
diagnosed and treated and how successful
those treatments can be these
large-scale data sets are continuing to
be collected and today we have the all
of us data set as well the all of us
research program which is led by the
national institutes of health is
building one of the largest biomedical
data resources of its kind the all of us
research hub stores health data from a
diverse group of participants from
across the united states researchers can
access all of us data and tools to
conduct studies to help improve our
understanding of human health
now it also provides us with a much
better understanding of what we call
healthy or the variation of healthy
individuals that can be used as a
reference when we study subgroups of
patients or patients that are of
different ages sexes
ethnic backgrounds
and socioeconomic status in addition
there are projects that are aimed at
characterizing the healthy condition
and preclinical variation
one such example is the nih human
microbiome project that allows us to
look at different types of microbiome
perturbation that is associated with
different types of diseases
these include depression
autism spectrum disorder cardiovascular
disease asthma arthritis cancer and
diabetes
by understanding the microbiome
diversity composition and changes
associated with different types of
phenotypes we can start seeing the
impact of the microbiome on diagnostics
but also treatment because patients with
different microbiome can metabolize
treatment at different rates
now that we have reviewed the rationale
for bioinformatics and ngs in biomedical
research in the clinic let's review case
studies of clinical research with real
data
these include oncology neurodegenerative
diseases like alzheimer's disease and
infectious diseases like covet 19
malaria or ebola we can look at how
viral genomics and evolution can help us
understand the spread of a disease and
identify variants of concern in
pathogens
or genetic predisposition of some
populations to be more susceptible to
acquire disease
and potentially
have worse outcomes we can look at
immune responses where we characterize
gene expression and study biomarkers or
genes that are associated with a
particular response and sometimes we can
look at microbiome and see how
microbiome plays a role in disease
progression drug metabolism and also
predisposes certain people to different
clinical risks on the onyx logic portal
you will find a number of case studies
and curated data sets around these
different topics some of them are based
on full analysis of data sets that are
already published
simply by following the steps described
in these case studies you will be able
to make important discoveries that today
are being used in the clinic some of
them have to do with drug metabolism
identification of somatic mutations in
tumor development
inherited or germline mutations like the
sickle cell anemia rare genetic diseases
as well as drug resistance associated
with different types of antibiotics and
pathogens oftentimes just by reading the
abstract you get a good grasp of how
bioinformaticians can use such data to
model precision medicine for example on
this project modeling precision medicine
of breast cancer you will find how
researchers use machine learning to
study transcriptomic data and identify
subgroups of individuals
that are going to respond differently to
different treatments in the study
researchers use multi-omics data
integration to look at different types
of molecular profiles
integrate them and compare them to
reference databases like the tcga
to understand response to treatment to
drugs that are either already used in
the clinic or being studied in clinical
trials to continue learning we invite
you to explore these associated
resources for the lecture
we will go over the coursework the case
studies and other examples from
literature
to benefit from today's lecture you can
select one of these to refresh your
memory of basic terminology
learn more about the various techniques
or practice what we have learned with
curated data sets on the topics that we
covered in today's session
the contents of the session correspond
with practical lessons that you can
complete independently that are
available on the onyx logic learn portal
with the full course specific lessons
that are of relevance to today's session
include lesson 2 bioinformatics in
healthcare from course 1 introduction to
bioinformatics
in this lesson you will get an overview
of examples from healthcare area where
bioinformatics can be applied you will
also see examples and videos of medical
professionals discussing bioinformatics
and precision medicine applications
another good course to look at is bytes
and molecules
this course is a great place for those
who was confused by a lot of the terms
that we used in today's lecture anyone
that would like to review the basic
terminology and get a good overview of
topics that we cover in this course
should look at this course in full but
specifically we looked at this lesson
lesson six called introduction to
genomics if you are interested in
genomics you can also look at these
additional lessons in the course three
course called genomics in lesson two you
will see how you can work with dna
sequences in r
and in lesson 3 you will get an
introduction to large scale genomics the
full course contains a lot more
information that you can choose to
explore independently some of these will
be covered in the future lectures but do
not worry about completing them for now
at the end you will also find examples
that i already mentioned
these examples include such projects
like ebola
immune response changes in cancer
modeling cancer precision medicine
or tuberculosis infection and treatment
finding drug resistance variants
so let's recap what we have learned so
far
first
we learned how combining clinical and
molecular data helps reveal underlying
factors contributing to the disease
which further helps us provide a precise
diagnosis and effective treatment to the
patient
further we learned about next generation
sequencing technologies for genomic
transcriptomic and metagenomic data that
provide important insights for precision
medicine applications
we also discussed the role of
bioinformatics in taking research
results from the lab to the clinic to
benefit patient treatment and diagnosis
finally we introduced a set of case
studies in precision medicine from
inherited sickle cell anemia to drug
resistance in mycobacterium tuberculosis
in the next session session two on
genomic data analysis we will go one
step further to better understand what
is genomic data
how do you perform variant calling
analysis
what is the difference between germline
and somatic mutations
and how to determine a variance clinical
relevance
at the end of session 2 you will have a
thorough understanding of genomic data
variant calling analysis as well as
specific techniques for clinical
annotation of variants in cancer